- Il y a beaucoup de choses
entre le pont Jacques-Cartier
et le centre-ville de Montréal.
Donc, ça devient très difficile
de passer avec une solution
en tunnel, bien, très difficile,
dans beaucoup de cas,
impossible.
- Difficile ou impossible?
- C'est impossible, oui,
impossible.
Jean-Marc Arbaud, président
et chef de la direction
de CDPQ Infra.
Bonsoir.
Vous me disiez à l'époque, c'est
impossible.
Vous aviez déjà dit en image que
ça pourrait s'écrouler tout ça.
Or ce n'était pas impossible.
- On est revenu aujourd'hui de
façon détaillée pour aller
jusqu'au bout de la démarche.
Pour dire oui comme les
journalistes dont j'ai oublié le
nom à préciser vraiment début.
On a regardé les solutions
importantes.
Sous les lignes de métro entre
les lignes de métro.
Avec l'étude au final, ils ont
dit mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
garde pas un peu au-dessus des
lignes, de profiter de la pente
naturelle pour pouvoir amener
une solution dans le tunnel de
surface cours en surface.
Ça, ça fonctionne.
Ça va se réaliser.
C'est plus court. C'est une
solution intéressante puisque
dans le même cadre que ce qu'on
fait dans nos études. On part
d'un projet de référence on
essaye d'amener des
améliorations tout au long s'il
n'y avait pas eu toute levée de
boucliers de gens qui ont dit on
va défigurer le centre-ville
etc. etc.
Il faut qu'on poursuive la
réflexion sur un tunnel. Vous,
vous n'aviez pas l'intention de
faire aucun tunnel que ce soit?
- Non nous on...
on a toujours la même démarche.
On continue de l'avoir.
Sur le REM, il faut toujours
chercher. On parle de projet de
référence. On optimise. On a les
consultations publiques.
On essaie d'amener les
meilleures solutions de point de
vue pragmatique.
- On reconnaît que c'était donc
possible qu'il y ait une portion
de tunnel ce que vous trouviez
impossible il y a peu de temps.
- Oui. C'est possible avec une
solution pour avoir une portion
de tunnel.
Mais les autres, de tunnel dont
on parle.
Non.
Cela sont toujours impossibles.
C'était le débat important.
- Ce qui m'amène à notre
question.
Est-ce que vous dîtes encore sur
l'ensemble du centre-ville ne
sera pas un tunnel?
Pourquoi à ce moment-là faire un
tunnel de 500? 600?
- Ça va de Jeanne Mance...
- mais cette portion, pourquoi
faire un petit tunnel dans le
fond si le groupe du centre-
ville sera en aérien?
- Parce que ça permet d'avoir
une bonne intégration à la fin.
Ça aussi des avantages et
actions souterraines. Ça permet
d'avoir une connexion directe
avec tous les réseaux
souterrains de Montréal, ce qui
en aérien était plus complexe.
Ça permet aussi donc tout le
réseau. Donc tous les autres
lignes de transport que ce soit
le futur REM, la ligne orange ou
la ligne verte, ça permet aussi
de mettre en place une arrière-
garde, c'est-à-dire d'avoir une
zone de retournement des trains
à l'arrière de la gare qui
permet d'augmenter la fréquence
théorique future du projet.
- Quelles sont les prochaines
étapes?
Il y a un comité qui regarde.
Ce n'est pas clair pour moi.
- Le comité d'experts on l'a
créé et je pense que quand vous
m'avez parlé on parlait de vin
mettre en place. On a mis en
place un comité d'experts pour
regarder toute la problématique
de l'intégration urbaine et
architecturale de l'ensemble du
projet. Et puis on a présenté
depuis on ne se comité d'experts
qui a été mis en place avec le
gouvernement du Québec. Ces
experts on a eu huit réunions
avec eux. On a examiné... on
leur présente l'ensemble des
dossiers de la même façon que
les dossiers qu'on a présentés
d'analyse technique etc. de
pourquoi pas des solutions en
tunnel.
Alors on présente ses dossiers
et à la fin ils font un rapport
par rapport à l'intégration
architecturale urbaine.
Donc la prochaine étape, c'est
qu'on va présenter cet automne
l'ensemble de la programmation
architecturale et urbaine pour
toute la partie interne.
- Et vous continuez à plaider
que la partie aérienne qui est
la majeure partie du projet
pourra s'intégrer
harmonieusement à une cité comme
Montréal?
- Oui.
On continue à plaider ça.
On fait tous les efforts. On est
vraiment conscient de la
problématique d'intégration.
Et il faut réaliser cette
intégration.
On met tous les efforts pour le
faire.
- Si le gouvernement du Québec
voyant que... je ne sais pas...
la grogne prenne de l'ampleur,
si le gouvernement du Québec
vous disait : allez-y mettez de
la gomme fait un tunnel sur
toute la centre-ville est-ce que
vous diriez c'est terminé?
On ne le fera pas?
- Je vais répondre ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui dévoilé avec
l'ensemble des études au travers
de ça. Ce convoi, c'est que ces
réaliser un tunnel sur toute la
longueur C de rentrer dans un
projet qu'il est impossible de
circonscrire tant d'un point de
vue financier que d'un point de
vue de coût. Il n'y a pas un
contractant dans le monde qui
prendrait le risque de réaliser
ce genre de projet clé en main.
Je ne veux pas entrer dans les
détails. Donc à la fin, pour ma
part, pour ma position, ce ne
serait pas réaliste de
recommander à qui que ce soit de
s'engager dans un projet dont on
ne sait pas définir les limites.
- Est-ce que vous pourriez, dans
un cas comme celui-là,
est-ce que vous pourriez dire
CDPQ se retire?
- On ne peut pas entrer dans un
projet comme ça. Encore une
fois. On ne peut pas le
recommander. C'est un projet
qu'on ne recommandera pas. On ne
peut pas le recommander. On ne
recommandait par le
gouvernement.
Il n'y a pas de différence de
désir d'entrer dans ce projet-
là. On a mit les analyses pour
le montrer.
- Très bien.
On va suivre ensemble ce projet.
Plus les documents sont publics,
plus la discussion s'éclaire.
- Oui.
- N'est-ce pas?
C'est un bout de temps qu'on
demande les études.
- On a eu les discussions en
mars. On a eu un premier
rapport. On a publié un deuxième
rapport.
On a fait des rapports
complémentaires avec excellents
résultats avec le comité
d'experts.
On échange tous ces résultats
avant de les rendre publiques.
Je pense compter un bon rythme à
dévoiler les documents, à
expliquer et à être transparent
vis-à-vis du dévoilement du
projet